>> Jesse: NOBODY WANTS TO BE
LAST, ESPECIALLY THE LAST TO
LEARN SOMETHING.
YOU REALLY DON'T WANT TO BE THE
LAST ONE AT WORK TO FIND OUT
YOUR GIRLFRIEND IS CHEATING.
>> UH, YOU'RE NOT THE GUY.
>> YOU CHEATED ON ME?
WHEN I SPECIFICALLY ASKED YOU
NOT TO.
>> Jesse: THE GUY THAT FIGURES
IT OUT LAST.
WOULD YOU PUT THAT GUY IN
CHARGE?
OF COURSE NOT.
BUT WE DID.
WE PUT JOE BIDEN IN CHARGE OF
THE COUNTRY, AND HE CONTINUES TO
BE THE LAST ONE TO KNOW WHAT'S
HAPPENING.
JOE DID WARN US HE'S NOT A
MINDREADER, BUT ALL WE'RE ASKING
FOR, JOE, JUST BE A READER.
READ THE NEWSPAPER.
READ THE ROOM.
READ THE WRITING ON THE WALL.
>> SHOULD THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
PREPARE FOR A RECESSION?
>> NO.
LOOK, THEY'VE BEEN SAYING THIS
NOW EVERY SIX MONTHS.
EVERY SIX MONTHS THEY LOOK DOWN,
THE NEXT SIX MONTHS, THEY SEE
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN.
IT HADN'T HAPPENED YET.
THERE IS NO -- THERE'S NO
GUARANTEE THAT THEY'RE GOING
TO -- I DON'T THINK THERE WILL
BE A RECESSION.
IF IT IS, IT WILL BE A SLIGHT
RECESSION.
>> Jesse: I THOUGHT THIS WAS THE
GREATEST ECONOMY OF ALL TIME.
ISN'T THAT WHAT THEY SAID?
HOW DID WE GO FROM BUILD BACK
BETTER TO A SLIGHT RECESSION?
THE ECONOMY HASN'T GROWN IN A
YEAR.
ALL YEAR.
AND HUNTER'S WILL HAVE TO HOLD
MORE THAN 10 FOR THE BIG GUY.
THE MARKETS ARE DOWN 25% THIS
YEAR.
IF JOE BIDEN SAYS SOMETHING IS
NOT GOING TO HAPPEN, I GUARANTEE
YOU IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN.
THE TALIBAN WON'T TAKE OVER
AFGHANISTAN, INFLATION IS GOING
AWAY, HE'S GOING TO CRUSH THE
VIRUS.
YEAH.
WAS HE EVEN SUPPOSED TO SAY THE
WORD "RECESSION"?
HE CAN'T EVEN READ WHAT'S ON HIS
NOTECARD.
HE CAN'T EVEN HOLD IT.
>> WE PASSED LEGISLATION THAT
SIGNIFICANTLY MAKES A POINT
ABOUT --
>> Jesse: YEAH.
BIDEN DID GET A LOT OF
LEGISLATION PASSED.
SO WHAT.
I CAN COOK A LOT OF DINNERS.
DOESN'T MAKE THEY TASTE ANY
GOOD.
TRADITIONAL AMERICAN ENERGY IS
THE KEY TO GETTING US OUT OF THE
RECESSION.
BUT JPMORGAN'S CEO, KIND OF A
SMART GUY, SAYS WE'RE GETTING
ENERGY COMPLETELY WRONG.
>> I THINK WE'RE GETTING ENERGY
COMPLETELY WRONG.
PEOPLE HAVE THIS BAD ASSUMPTION
THAT HIGHER OIL PRICES AND GAS
PRICES, REDUCE CONSUMPTION,
REDUCE CO2.
NO.
POOR NATIONS ARE TURNING BACK ON
COAL PLANTS AS ARE GERMANY,
NETHERLANDS AND FRANCE.
THE WORLD IS NOT PRODUCING
ENOUGH OIL AND GAS TO REDUCE
COAL, MAKE THE TRANSITION.
>> Jesse: LOOK AT EUROPE RIGHT
NOW.
THEY'RE FIGHTING OVER FUEL IN
EUROPE.
WHY DO THEY FIGHT?
BECAUSE THE WINDMILLS AND THE
SOLAR PANELS AREN'T WORKING
THERE FOR THE PEOPLE.
THEY RATION FUEL IN EUROPE.
THERE'S LINES LIKE CARTER HAD IN
THE '70s.
WHAT DO YOU THINK IS GOING TO
HAPPEN WHEN WE DEPEND ON CHINA
TO GO GREEN?
LINES AND FIGHTS.
DO YOU WANT TO GET INTO A FIGHT
AT THE GAS STATION?
IF THE EUROPEANS ARE THROWING
PUNCHES OVER FUEL, WHAT DO YOU
THINK THE AMERICANS WILL DO?
EXACTLY.
THINGS ARE GETTING SO BAD IN
EUROPE, THAT EVEN GRETA ADMITS
MAYBE GOING GREEN ISN'T TOO GOOD
OF AN IDEA.
>> ON THE CLIMATE ISSUE, THE
NUCLEAR POWER PLANTS, THE BETTER
CHOICE FOR THE TIME BEING NOW?
>> IT DEPENDS.
IF WE HAD THEM ALREADY RUNNING,
I FEEL IT'S A MISTAKE TO CLOSE
THEM DOWN IN ORDER TO FOCUS ON
COAL.
>> Jesse: LITERAL CHILDREN ARE
TELLING US WE NEED NUKE PLANTS.
THIS IS LIKE THE BEATLES.
WHAT HAPPENS IN EUROPE ALWAYS
COMES TO THE U.S.
GAS PRICES ARE HEADING BACK UP
TO $4 RIGHT BEFORE THE MIDTERMS.
SINCE JOE WON'T LET US DRILL,
HE'S BEGGING THE SAUDIS TO PUMP
MORE.
HE FIST-BUMPED THE CROWN PRINCE
AND EXPECTED OUR ALLIES TO GET
THEIR PUMP ON.
WHAT WERE THE SAUDIS GOING TO
DO?
WERE THEY GOING TO INCREASE
PRODUCTION AND LOWER THE PRICE
OR DECREASE PRODUCTION AND RAISE
THE PRICE?
RIGHT BEFORE THE BIG OPEC
MEETING, ACCORDING TO THE "WALL
STREET JOURNAL," U.S. OFFICIALS
CALLED THEIR COUNTERPARTS IN
SAUDI ARABIA AND OTHER BIG GULF
PRODUCERS WITH AN URGENT APPEAL,
DELAY THE DECISION FOR ANOTHER
MONTH.
WHY A MONTH?
WHY NOT A WEEK OR TWO MONTHS?
WHAT'S SO SPECIAL ABOUT A MONTH
FROM NOW?
WAIT A SECOND.
ISN'T THAT WHEN PEOPLE HEAD TO
THE POLLS FOR THE MIDTERMS?
IT IS, ISN'T IT?
DOESN'T IT KIND OF SOUND LIKE
JOE BIDEN IS DEMANDING THE
SAUDIS DO HIM A POLITICAL FAVOR?
THAT'S WHAT THE SAUDIS THOUGHT
TOO.
"WALL STREET JOURNAL" SAYS THEY
VIEWED IT AS A POLITICAL GAM BET
BY THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION TO
AVOID BAD NEWS AHEAD OF THE U.S.
MIDTERM ELECTIONS, SO THEY SAID
NO TO JOE.
THEY'RE GOING TO CUT PRODUCTION
AND INCREASE OIL PRICES.
WAIT A SECOND.
ARE YOU TELLING ME THAT JOE
BIDEN, A STATESMAN, THE FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT, THE FORMER CHAIR
OF THE FOREIGN RELATIONS
COMMITTEE, MR. DIPLOMAT,
MR. I'VE BEEN TO EVERY COUNTRY
AND KNOW EVERY LEADER, WASN'T HE
GOING TO WORK HIS CHARM ON THE
CROWN PRINCE?
THAT DIDN'T WORK?
APPARENTLY THE MEETING BIDEN HAD
WITH HIM WAS A DISASTER.
ACCORDING TO THE REPORT IN
AUGUST, THE SAUDIS PLANNED TO
PUSH OPEC TO RAISE OIL
PRODUCTION BY 500,000 BARRELS A
DAY IN AN EFFORT TO PLEASE
MR. BIDEN, BUT PRINCE MUHAMMAD
ORDERED THE INCREASE LOWER TO A
TOKEN 100,000 BARRELS A DAY
AFTER THE BIDEN VISIT.
WHAT DID JOE DO DURING THAT
MEETING THAT MADE THE SAUDIS SO
ANGRY?
DID JOE DO WHAT HE USUALLY DOES,
AND LIE AND TELL WEIRD STORIES?
DID HE TELL THE PRINCE HE WAS
RAISED A MUSLIM OR THAT HE TOOK
A PILGRIMAGE TO MECCA?
WE THOUGHT YO WAS THE ADULT IN
THE ROOM.
THE SAUDIS DON'T LIKE US
ANYMORE.
OUR ALLY UKRAINE IS A PILE OF
RUBBLE.
THE MEXICANS THINK OUR BORDER IS
A SUGGESTION.
ALL BIDEN CARES ABOUT, YEAH,
POLITICS.
HIS WHITE HOUSE IS SAYING,
QUOTE, THE OPEC DECISION WAS
UNHELPFUL.
IT THREATENS TO DRIVE UP
AMERICAN GASOLINE PRICES AHEAD
OF THE NOVEMBER 8 MIDTERMS.
WAIT.
IS THE BIDEN WHITE HOUSE, ARE
THEY PRESSURING THE SAUDIS TO
PUMP MORE OIL TO HELP THE
DEMOCRATS IN THE MIDTERMS?
HMM.
NOW, SINCE THEY DIDN'T, BIDEN'S
PROMISING TO RETALIATE.
HE'S THREATENING TO WITHHOLD
MILITARY AID TO OUR ALLIES IF
THEY DON'T DO HIM A POLITICAL
FAVOR.
>> THEY'RE CALLING FOR A
STOPPING OF U.S. ARM SALES TO
SAUDI ARABIA.
DO YOU SUPPORT THAT LEGISLATION?
>> WE'RE GOING TO REACT TO SAUDI
ARABIA.
WE WILL TAKE ACTION.
>> Jesse: IS BIDEN THREATENING
TO CANCEL OVER $100 MILLION IN
MILITARY SALES TO THE SAUDIS?
HE'S MAKING IT CLEAR TO THE
MIDDLE EASTERN ALLIES THEY
BETTER SERVE UP THE OIL.
AND DEMOCRATS ARE DENOUNCING THE
POLITICAL SHAKEDOWN.
WATCH.
>> THERE NEED TO BE
CONSEQUENCES.
WE AGREE COMPLETELY.
ONE OF THE CONSEQUENCES SHOULD
BE A TEMPORARY HALT IN ARMS
SALES.
>> WHAT GALLS MANY OF US IS THE
INGRATITUDE.
WE PROVIDE SAUDI ARABIA WITH
OVER 70% OF THEIR ARMS.
ONE OF THOSE CONSEQUENCES IS
SUSPENDING THE ARMS SALES TO THE
SAUDIS.
>> Jesse: JOE AND THE DEMOCRATS
ARE TWISTING THE SAUDIS' ARMS
UNTIL THEY GIVE HIM WHAT THEY
WANT?
ISN'T THERE A WORD FOR THAT?
FEELS LIKE THE DEMOCRATS USE
THAT A LOT WITH TRUMP.
WHAT'S THAT WORD AGAIN?
MAYBE JOE CAN SPARK OUR MEMORY
WITH THIS TWEET FROM THAT YEAR,
2019.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WITHHELD
CONGRESSIONALLY APPROPRIATED TO
UKRAINE UNLESS THEY GRANTED HIM
A POLITICAL FAVOR.
IT'S THE DEFINITION OF QUID PRO
QUO.
THIS IS NO JOKE.
TRUMP CONTINUES TO PUT HIS OWN
PERSONAL POLITICAL INTERESTS
AHEAD OF THE NATIONAL INTERESTS.
HE MUST BE IMPEACHED.
QUID PRO QUO.
THAT'S IT AGAIN.
REMEMBER WHEN THEY IMPEACHED
TRUMP FOR ASKING ZELENSKI.
>> WITHHOLDING AID TO AN ALLY,
AND THEN, QUOTE, UNQUOTE, ASKING
FOR A FAVOR TO ESSENTIALLY
BENEFIT YOURSELF POLITICALLY.
>> QUID PRO QUO?
BRIBERY.
THE BRIBERY IS TO GRANT OR
WITHHOLD MILITARY ASSISTANCE.
>> THE IDEA THAT SOMEBODY WOULD
WITHHOLD BADLY NEEDED WEAPONRY
FOR POLITICAL REASONS AT HOME IS
BEYOND THE PALE.
>> Jesse: THE SAUDIS ACTUALLY
THOUGHT JOE BIDEN WAS BEING
POLITICAL.
AND AID WAS DELAYED.
DEMOCRATS NOW ARE JUST SAYING
DON'T SEND IT.
THAT'S IT.
WHERE ARE ALL THE DEMOCRATS
CALLING FOR IMPEACHMENT?
YOU WON'T HEAR THEM, BECAUSE
WHAT TRUMP DID WAS NEVER AN
IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE FROM THE
START.